في حين أن رياضة التجديف هي رياضة جديدة تمامًا ،
فهي تبدأ بقفزة إيمانية من المدرسة القديمة ، حيث يحبس
المشاركون أنفاسهم
وهم يصدون الوديان التي تبدو بلا قاع والتي
تشكلت على ما يبدو بقرون من الرياح
والمياه من خلال الشلالات القادمة حول
المنعطفات العمياء والمتدلية فوق المنحدرات
الرواد الرياضيين  استمتع بالعجائب الطبيعية التي
لن يجرؤ عليها بقيتنا أبدًا ، كيب
تورنر هو أحد هؤلاء الرواد الذي
هو وفريقه على وشك الدخول إلى كانيون بوكس كندا لأ
ل مرة ، وهو المكان الذي سي
عل ركبتيهم ترتعش ، لق
بدأت في الجري في الأخاديد في ها
اي.  تسلق الصخور وفي النهاية
أحرزت تقدمًا في منطقة الوادي ،
ثم بصفتي صديقتي ، كانت
فتاة من هاواي ولدت وترعرعت ، كنا نتواعد
الآن منذ ما يقرب من عامين ،
التقينا بطفل متسلق يدفعني دائمًا إلى
الذهاب إلى مستوى الراحة الخاص بي والكثير
عندما  نتحدث عن
التجديف في عملية نزول الوادي ،
عليك أن تقرر مقدار الحبل الذي تريد
إحضاره معك وتريد أن تقرر ما إذا كانت
جودة الصخور ستنتهي  كن جيدًا بما يكفي
لإنشاء مراسي للبعثات ،
عليك أيضًا العثور على طاقم جيد
يتعرض للضغط ، فأنت تتعامل فقط مع
الكثير من تعقيدات الطبيعة الصخرية
الشلال ، إنه مجرد
حل دائم للمشكلات باستخدام عقلك باستخدام
البصل.  متقلب للغاية
ويعتمد ذلك بشدة على الظروف الجوية في الوادي
يمكن أن تتغير من يوم إلى آخر
من موسم إلى آخر
لهذا الوادي الخاص بعلبة كانيون
التي يتعين عليك عبورها عبر نهر سكواميش
والتجديف بالكاياك عبر النهر لم تكن
صفقة لدينا  لأنه عليك فقط أن
تجدف قلبك للخارج لمجرد قطع
هذا التيار ، ثم عليك أن تجعله
حادًا تتحول إلى واجهة الشاطئ الصغيرة هذه ،
لذلك بمجرد عبور النهر ،
هناك نزهة مليئة بالبعوض إلى
قاع  مربع الوادي
الدفق ثم تنزه في اتجاه المنبع لفترة من
الوقت قبل أن تصل إلى الجزء الفني
من الوادي الذي يتضمن حبلًا
، كان الفكر الأول هو أن هذا من صنع الإنسان
وهذا ليس حقيقيًا يبدو وكأنه
حرف D  يعتبر كانيون جزيرة جزيرة ركوب الخيل
من فئة C
كانيون ،
معظمه يصد إذا لم يكن كل الصواعق
التي تمر بها مباشرة عبر
المجرى المائي الذي يمر مباشرة
عبر الشلال وأنت
تتعرض للقصف بالمياه التي تصطدم بها في
سيارتك  وجهك وأنت تنزلق ، فأنت تنزلق في
كل مكان ، الشيء المفضل لدي
في السقوط في الوادي هو
الاندفاع إلى تجاوز الحافة ، هذا هو
شغفي ، ثم مثلما أحصل على المزيد من النفخات
للعيش في الوادي ، فهذا يضيف نوعًا ما
عنصر الإثارة حيث لا يمكنك أن
ترى أين ستنتهي
عندما تكون على حافة الهاوية كمغامر
عندما تشعر وكأنني قد أموت أثناء القيام
بذلك الآن ولكن لا يمكنني التراجع
ثم تفعل ذلك  مثل أكثر
المشاعر المدهشة
، لا أفهم الأشخاص الذين يشبهون
لماذا تفعل ذلك
، فأنا أحب فقط لماذا لا إذا لم تفهم
ذلك ، فلن تحصل عليه لشخص
يبحث عن كل ما فعلناه وهو
بإسقاط كل شيء والسعي وراء
أحلامهم ، أود أن أقول إن هذا أمر مؤكد
إنها قفزة إيمانية وربما تصطدم
وتحترق ، لكن اللحظات المرتفعة لا تصدق
ولن تحصل أبدًا على تلك
اللحظات الرائعة وترى ما إذا كان بإمكانك حقًا
تحقيق أحلامك إذا لم تجرب
[موسيقى]